sometimes even one phone call can
seriously change the entire history of
mankind september 1970 an article
appeared in a squire magazine that
dramatically changed the life of a
student from san jose the secret of the
little blue box described how talented
attackers deceived phone networks with
the help of a children's toy the sound
of a boat swain's pipe from a captain
crunch lunchbox was precisely a match to
the signal of an automatic switchboard
one simply had to whistle in the phone
at the right time to make a free
long-distance call
in just a few weeks a young guy hiding
behind the pseudonym berkeley blue
created a digital device that mimicked
these signals
together with a friend he set up a
garage production
the components only cost about 40
dollars so he was clearing a tidy profit
offering 150 bucks for the finished
product
in a couple of months the two steves yes
him his friend had the same name
earned more than six thousand dollars
they planned to use the money to build
their own computer but these plans were
not destined to become a reality their
plans were foiled by their own strange
sense of humor one day with the help of
their invention they called the vatican
one of the steves introduced himself as
henry kissinger the at the time united
states secretary of state and then asked
to be connected with the pope
despite the fact that it was five in the
morning italian time the secretary woke
up paul v
obviously he was furious about the silly
prank and ordered that the perpetrators
should be punished it took the police
just a couple of months to find the
unlucky pranksters and they turned out
to be some young student named steve
wozniak and his friend steve jobs the
att phone company joined the lawsuit
wozniak and jobs were both found guilty
of fraud
and sent to prison for five years
they served the entire term and were
released only in 1976
the trial broke up the duo and they
never worked again g'day everyone my
name is lucas and today i will tell you
about a world without apple
[Music]
okay so that story isn't entirely true
but
it could have been in november 1970 jobs
and wozniak did actually call the pope
uh with their invention but the
pontiff's secretary thankfully wasn't so
gullible and decided not to wake up paul
v let's return to the history of
technological developments apple is
often considered to be the creator of
the first mass personal computer the
apple ii this is not actually true
though the first personal computer
appeared on the market in 1975 and it
was created by henry roberts and based
the latest intel 8080 processor the
altair 8800 was sold either
pre-assembled for 621 or as a
self-assembled kit at 439
over the next three years roberts
managed to sell 25 000 computers he
couldn't have believed his success
roberts only expected to sell about 100
computers a month
now the success of altair helped another
person start their business it was on
this computer that bill gates wrote his
first commercially successful product
an interpreter for basic programming
language it took him just 30 days to put
it together and in order to make a deal
gates created a company that he named
microsoft we'll come back to gates a
little bit later the architecture of the
altair 8800 became a source of
inspiration for steve wozniak so in 1975
the apple one appeared and to be fair
compared to robert's computer it looked
extremely unassuming basically just a
wooden box with some dials
it was built around the cheapest
microprocessor on the market the mos
6502
comparable processors from intel and
motorola cost upwards of 200 bucks
and the 6502 just sold for 25
this made it possible to build a
computer for 500
jobs and wozniak managed to interest
only one person in their development the
owner of a computer store paul terrell
there were huge wait lists for the
altair the company couldn't satisfy
everyone who wanted to buy a computer so
paul decided to take a chance and he
ordered a batch of 50 apple computers
in total about 200 apple computers were
released but jobs and wozniak invested
all of the returns in the development of
the improved apple ii model many people
call the apple ii the first truly
popular personal computer of course more
than six million of which were sold and
this definitely exceeds altair's 25 000.
it's pretty good but it was in 1979 that
the company succeeded by releasing a
program that really turned the world
around
i'm talking about this calc spreadsheets
the idea of this program came to a man
called daniel brooklyn during a lecture
on economics here's that classroom they
put up a plaque to commemorate what
happened there back then complex tables
with financial calculations had to be
completely rewritten if at least one
parameter changed the lecturer did it on
a blackboard with a piece of chalk
erasing the old numbers and writing down
new ones and the students had to rewrite
everything over and over again so
naturally daniel imagined that if you
could transfer the board to the computer
you would be able to automate a huge
number of calculations it only took
brooklyn a week to develop the first
version of the program
but even in this version we can already
see the features of spreadsheets that
are pretty familiar to all of us today
brooklyn created vizcalc on his home
computer which happened to be the apple
ii the application sparked a real
revolution the apple ii was transformed
from an entertainment device to a
business tool a simple and intuitive
interface allowed financiers accountants
with no understanding of programming to
use the computer in just six years they
managed to sell 700 000 copies of this
program moreover it could only be run on
an expensive apple ii model with its
whopping 32 kilobytes of ram the demand
for it grew so much that many dealers
sold the computers with vizcalc already
pre-installed during the year apple
became the leader of the personal
computer market
this success even prompted ibm managers
to develop personal computers for
business and this is how the chess
project appeared which later then turned
into ibm pc computers i would hazard a
guess that without viscalc and apple the
introduction of computers into offices
would have appeared much later
large american companies in the early
80s would have continued to work using
the old-fashioned way calculators
pencils and this would have affected the
entire economy without new information
technologies companies would have been
looking for a way out of the 1982
economic crisis for a lot longer most
likely the success of reaganomics would
have been in question which means that
in 1984
walter mondale could have become the
41st president of the united states and
this would have changed the country's
foreign policy the cold war with the
soviet union could have gone on for at
least until the mid 90s the iron curtain
would still divide berlin into its
western and communist parts and the
military campaigns in libya would have
never begun
back to computers the success of this
cal confirmed jobs belief that computers
were needed not only for engineers and
programmers the trouble was that
computers were very difficult to use for
everybody else
most of the work was done by a command
line users had to memorize dozens of
commands for each program therefore in
1979 the apple team started developing a
fundamentally new type of interface
graphical interfaces
once again we're faced with a
misconception apple in fact was not the
first company to address this issue the
first graphical interface was created by
xerox engineers in march 1973 two years
before the first apple computer appeared
they released the first 30 alto
computers a desktop appeared on the
screens for the first time and a
computer mouse was used to work with
programs in addition to the keyboard
over 10 years later xerox released a
little more than 2000 of these computers
yet
maybe unfortunately for them they were
mainly used internally in their offices
of the company itself
the graphical interface of the apple
lisa computer which was presented to the
public in 1983
largely repeated the developments of
xerox and this isn't surprising jobs not
only saw the alto but he also managed to
lure a group of engineers involved in
its development to his company
an echo of this story will later be the
skirmish of the fight between jobs and
gates in 1985 when microsoft introducing
its graphical operating system windows 1
is accused by jobs of plagiarism in
response to that he replies well it was
you who borrowed these ideas from xerox
therefore in a world without apple the
familiar graphical interfaces of
computers would undoubtedly have
appeared eventually in the market but a
couple years later the amount of memory
of ibm and pc computers would not allow
them at the time to be released earlier
oh and gates would have made a bit more
money i think more noticeable changes
would also affect the publishing
business in our world in 1985 apple
released a revolutionary application for
its macintosh computer
the desktop publishing system page maker
newspapers magazines and books began to
be designed not by manually organizing
templates and blocks of texts in a
printing house but with the help of
computers directly in the editorial
office the author of pagemaker was a man
named paul brenard until 1983 he worked
as a developer for atex but then kodak
bought the company and paul's department
was closed at the beginning of 1984
fortuitously he had a meeting with jobs
bernard shared his idea of an electronic
publishing system with jobs who showed
off his new desktop environment the
development of the first version took
more than a year and the page maker
version for other platforms appeared
only in july 1987. by that time
macintosh had already firmly established
itself in all major publishing houses
apple sales for the first time
significantly overtook atari and amiga
without jobs of support paige maker
would have forever remained just a
beautiful idea in brainerd's head of
course the guys from adobe or xerox
would eventually come to this sort of
idea one way or another but it wouldn't
have appeared before the mid-1990s and
then other editors such as illustrator
or photoshop would have then appeared
even a few years later most likely the
delay in the introduction of new
technologies would have greatly
undermined the publishers and newspapers
of magazines at the end of the 80s they
were already losing the battle for
eyeballs to informational tv channels
and a sharp reduction in product cost
was the only way for them to stay afloat
it turns out that in a world without
apple
we would have had to say goodbye to the
morning paper much earlier
[Music]
so we can safely skip over the next 12
years or so in 1985 of course jobs was
fired from his own company i'm not going
to go into the details but i will note
that over those years apple did not
release a single breakthrough product to
the market
at the beginning of the 2000s
the company was on the verge of death
apple losses for the year 2000 amounted
to 25 million the turnover fell by a
third in just a year
only a miracle could save the company
and it happened october 23rd 2001 steve
jobs presented
the ipod
there it is right there
it's hard to appreciate how crazy this
seemed back then a once outstanding
computer manufacturer hoped to improve
its position with the help of an mp3
player are you serious the ipod was not
the first mp3 player it wasn't
distinguished by any advanced technical
solutions and besides it was only
compatible with apple computers in the
first months of sales about 150 000
devices were sold
but this was only the first step towards
conquering the music market before the
advent of the ipod listeners either had
to download tracks from the internet or
convert them from purchased cds music
piracy was breaking all records record
companies naturally were coming up with
more and more ways to deal with it but
file sharing networks were winning
naturally job suggested a way out the
itunes store in its own platform in
which users could download individual
songs by popular artists for just 99
cents do you remember the advertising
slogan of the first ipod a thousand
songs in your pocket so in order to fill
it out legally the user would have to
spend exactly 990
not bad right
in fact there wasn't much left for the
company at first for example under an
agreement with universal apple had to
pay 70 cents for every dollar
but on the other hand the company did
receive 30 cents for each song without
even having to buy it themselves
at the same time jobs said that users
were tired of the tyranny of labels
they didn't need template commercial
compilations on cds listeners should be
able to make their own selection of
music without it being tied to physical
media the ipod and itunes store combo
just exploded onto the market
in the year after the launch of the
digital store users downloaded 70
million songs the ipod became as much of
a sort after item as the sony walkman
had been 20 years previous
in the first three years they sold less
than 2 million players two years later
that number increased to 10 million and
by the mid of 2006 there were already 58
million ipods purchased in fact half of
apple's revenue back then was in the
sale of digital music in a world without
apple we would still have to buy whole
albums to listen to just two or three
really worthwhile songs
well most likely we wouldn't even buy
them we'd download them from some
napster 3.0 and still be fiddling with
individual files and trojans executing
on our laptops sony would become a
monopoly in the legal music market
they could repeat the successor 20 years
earlier with their own sony music
library
other manufacturers would target their
mp3 players towards consumers of pirated
content eventually they would quickly
bring their main attention to the
smartphone market and things would
totally look different
[Music]
remember the popular mobile phones
before 2007 a bunch of buttons some with
touch screens others with joysticks
wheels sliders
finnish engineers especially like to
experiment a lot with the design
different nokia models resembled game
consoles lipstick cases they unfolded
they slid they flipped up
every year a new form appeared
but in 2007 the market changed
dramatically and the era of the glass
brick began the new benchmark for style
was set by one phone the iphone and the
history of the ipod was once again
repeated the unusual device was
discussed everywhere but most analysts
agreed it was just an expensive toy and
it wouldn't last on the market beyond a
couple years
well yes the smartphone's large screen
was admired but almost everything else
was criticized the input method in
particular took the most criticism
poking your finger at the screen is just
inconvenient without a stylus you can't
get to all those small buttons you can't
write a note by hand you can't make a
drawing
even those few phone models that were
created with an eye on the touchscreen
interface were still equipped with a
small pen for you to constantly lose and
just rediscover behind the back of your
sofa well jobs remembered why he had
started reorganizing the company after
his return
i'm talking about the closure of the
failed pda newton project a considerable
part of the blame for the failure of the
project was the issue of bad screens and
malfunctioning styluses
in the new device jobs completely
changed his approach he cut all
redundant features a collection of
buttons a pen a bunch of interfaces and
the ability to use mms only the most
basic features remains the harshest
critics compared the first generation of
the iphone too well
some sort of budget over the store phone
but once you've held an apple smartphone
in your hands
it's impossible to put it down
smooth animations clear reaction to
every touch really left the impression
of a smartphone from the future there
was no need for a stylus because there
were no small icons or elements to touch
it was the first truly made from scratch
phone
the pda's legacy weighed heavily on
everyone else and yet unlike the
flagship nokia sony or samsung an apple
smartphone could be bought at a very
affordable price with a contract it
could be bought for just 4.99 well you
know as well as i do what it led to in
the future the iphone pretty much went
on to dominate the direction of
smartphone development for two decades
in a world without apple we would still
be walking around with phones that were
distinguishable just by looking at them
without the manufacturer's logo
i think styluses would have become a
relic but proportions of the screens the
shape of the cases would differ much
more nokia would have remained the
market leader and would not have had to
make a deal with microsoft gradually
finnish engineers would refine the
promising migo and maybe it would become
the main competitor to android phones
plus we wouldn't be held hostage by the
vertical videos the trend that did come
along with the advent of iphones the
mobile gaming industry would change
developers would have had to create
dozens and dozens of different versions
on platforms so over time some kind of
universal technology might arise there'd
also be exclusive games and applications
and they would be widely used in
advertising for new phone releases
just like what happened with game
consoles the only thing i don't know
is who those guys from samsung would
have copied smartphone designs from
[Music]
so
let's summarize the results of my
extended thought experiment
the most noticeable different in a world
without apple occurred in both politics
and the entertainment industry
walter mondale
the presidential chair could have well
closed the way for h.w bush to be in
power but gradually the political
situation would have ended up pretty
similar to the presence the soviet union
would have collapsed the european union
would have begun a few years don't make
an especially big difference we would
have experienced the dot-com crisis in
the same way in the beginning of the web
2.0 era rampant digital privacy would
have contributed to maybe more active
development of peer-to-peer networks and
decentralized systems in general
you know i think perhaps even
cryptocurrencies could have appeared a
few years earlier but youtube streaming
services all of these would have
developed significantly slower
smartphones would not have gained
widespread popularity so quickly without
the iphone the era of mobile video would
have begun a few years later on the
other hand the guys from netflix would
have spent longer mailing dvds to our
mailboxes contrary to popular belief
apple has created practically no new
technologies steve jobs main talent was
that he was able to combine existing
solutions into amazing things it was the
combination of hardware and software
that is to thank for the magic of apple
magic without which our world might have
been a little worse off do you agree
with this or not let me know what you
think would have happened without the
mighty apple i'd love to read about what
other changes might have occurred well
this is lucas i'm sitting in sand and i
will see you soon in the weird and
wonderful world of the online jungle
[Music]
you